Believe it or not, you're already a quarter of the way through the course.
Excellent work. In the last unit, we learned about linear equations and
inequalities. We looked at how they can be represented using tables, graphs, and
equations. In this unit, we'll continue that approach. We'll look at not just
one line, but two. Two lines or two linear equations are considered to be a
systems of equations. Let's try to make meaning of these systems of equations by
renting a car. You're going to rent a car from a car company called Car-nival.
You have $45 to spend on the car rental and Car-nival is going to charge $5 for
a registration fee and $10 per hour for renting the car. So we're going to
figure out what's the longest time you can rent the car. You might already be
able to solve this problem in your head, but we're going to try a different
approach. We're going to use systems.